this salad sucks in fact most salads
suck most salads suck because people
don't know how to make salads so here's
how to make a salad that doesn't suck
first thing don't use iceberg lettuce or
any lettuce unless you really want your
salad to taste like a glass of water use
a variety of other greens to get a
better texture and flavor like spinach
kale arugula basil and cilantro yes
you can add herbs to your salad and it's
amazing second chop everything very fine
the more you can fit on your fork the
better it will taste in your mouth and
here's an extra tip the little finely
chopped cabbage makes a world of
difference third you'll never get fooled
just eating leaves so add substance like
chicken broccoli avocado berries
tomatoes tortilla chips seeds and nuts
these things will make your salad more
filling and more delicious and therefore
suck less the last step is to add
dressing but not too much you'd be
surprised how far a tablespoon will go
if you toss it enough now that's a salad
that doesn't suck